Good morning, John.
In my last video I complained.
And my first rant, of all my rants, was ranting
about ranting and why people enjoy ranting
and listening to rants so much when the world
is actually full of pretty cool stuff.
So in this video, to counteract that, I'm
going to be sharing fifteen of my very favorite
feelings in the world ever.
It's not gonna be super funny.
It's not gonna fire your dopamine receptors
in the same way that getting all jazzed up
and angry will, and it might not even be like
so relatable.
Instead of those things, I'm just going for
honest.
So, my favorite feelings.
Seeing two people that you really like get
married to each other and everybody in their
lives who love them have come together to
just be unironically sappy about how adorable
their faces are for a day.
Hanging out with an old friend for the first
time in years, and you've forgotten a lot
of the things about them, and you're hanging
out, and, you, they're just great!
And you're like "I like you so much!
We get along really well!
That's probably why we used to hang out like
every day."
Figuring out something super complicated like,
for example, uuuuuuuhhhhhh this thing.
It just sits there on the floor now.
That's not one of my favorite feelings: having
just junk lying around.
But the complicated thing can be like a real
problem that I face in my life or some contrived
thing from a book or a video game.
That moment of figuring it out is so great!
I guess, somewhat relatedly, just getting
better at stuff.
Like that moment when you realize that you
can now do something very easily that a year
ago would have been unthinkably difficult.
Having the power to feel comfortable being
me and having society recognize you for your
strengths is pretty rare and pretty rad and
I have that right now.
And I never want to take it for granted and
if I don't have it anymore, which is certainly
possible, I do not want to be bitter about
it.
Having someone you respect tell you that they
respect you - mh.
So good.
When you're reading a book and there are like
35 different weird plot threads that seem
to have nothing to do with each other until
one thing is removed or added to the equation
and suddenly they all form together this magnificent
tapestry of everything and it all fits together
and you're like "What just happened?!"
Love that, I love that a lot.
Doing something scary and having it go really
well.
Taking a hot shower in the dead of winter.
Smelling the first iris of the year.
Not like of an eyeball.
An iris is a plant, if you don't have those.
Don't sniff each other's eyeballs.
Unless it's consensual...
Maybe the best feeling of all feelings, that
I've ever had, is opening up and letting somebody
that you love see all your broken bits.
And then they're like "I don't mind, those
are pretty cool.
Here are mine, too."
And you're like "Yeah, no, I like those.
Those are cool.
That's fine.
We should hold, and hug."
Knowing that yes, this person that you love
loves you back and you can trust that and
you can know it forever.
Yeah!
Less good than that, but still very good,
is when the cat is like "Don't, you, stop
moving.
I need to cuddle you."
Another amazing feeling: learning things that
help me understand the world better.
Also helping people learn things that help
them understand the world better.
I'm gonna finish this list off with a feeling
that I thought would feel really good, but
now that I've experienced it a few times clearly
does not: watching bad people, who have done
bad things to me or to other people and I've
seen it happen, watching those people fail
or self-destruct or have bad things happen
to them, it never feels good.
Like watching bad people is sad when they're
successful and when they're failing.
It doesn't matter what's happening.
It's always just sad.
John, I'm gonna be honest, I found this video
surprisingly hard to make.
Even in a little corner of the internet that
we inhabit that is a very open and honest
and authentic place.
It was difficult to just share things that
I like.
I don't know why.
If it's self-consciousness or if it's like
I'm afraid that I'm bragging that I, like,
enjoy things in my life, which is, why would
you feel that way?
I don't know.
Apparently it's more fun to complain than
to appreciate but probably not better for
a person or the world in the long term.
So I know some of the things above were, like,
probably things that everybody agrees on and
some were very specific to me.
But I'd like to know in the comments if you
just want to open up and tell everybody else
some of your favorite feelings that would
be great.
And also if you want to open up about some
of your hang ups to consenting strangers,
probably down there as well.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.